there have been a number of high-profile
plagiarism scandals in politics
for example in 2016 melania trump gave a
speech at the republican national
convention
that directly plagiarized a 2008 speech
of michelle obama's
here's some of the text from melania
trump
you can see that it is a direct copy of
michelle obama's words
rock and i were raised with so many of
the same values
like you work hard for what you want in
life
that your word is your bond that you do
what you say you're gonna do
my parents impressed on me the values
that you work hard for what you want in
life
that your word is your bond and you do
what you say
and keep your promise that you treat
people
with dignity and respect even if you
don't know them
and even if you don't agree with them
that you treat people with respect
they thought and showed me values and
morals
in their daily life that is a lesson
that i continue to pass along to our son
and we need to pass those lessons
on to the many generations to follow
and barack and i set out to build
lives guided by these values and to pass
them on to the next generation because
we want our children and all children in
this nation
to know that the only limit to the
height of your achievements
is the reach of your dreams and your
willingness to work hard for them
because
because we want our children in this
nation to know
that the only limit to your achievements
is the strength of your dreams and your
willingness to work for them
[Applause]
plagiarism is the practice of taking
someone else's work or ideas in passing
them off as one's own
most people are aware that you shouldn't
do this that it's unethical to
plagiarize
where it gets murky however is that many
students aren't completely sure exactly
what constitutes plagiarism
in this presentation we are going to try
to make that clear
what constitutes plagiarism most people
know that you shouldn't be stealing
large chunks of text from others
but plagiarism can be more complex than
that
cutting and pasting a sentence or even a
part of a sentence from another source
and putting that into your own work as
if you've written it that's plagiarism
taking somebody else's work and cutting
and pasting it into your document
and then slightly rearranging the words
or changing a word here or there
that's plagiarism borrowing descriptions
or definitions directly from wikipedia
that's plagiarism
here is an example this is a wikipedia
entry on ernest hemingway
it says ernest miller hemingway was an
american author and journalist
his economical and understated style had
a strong influence on 20th century
fiction while his life of adventure and
his public image influenced later
generations
now imagine a student is writing about
ernest hemingway
so they go to wikipedia and they start
cutting and pasting bits and pieces from
the wikipedia entry
and they come up with the following
ernest hemingway's thrifty and
understated style strongly influenced
20th century fiction
his audacious lifestyle and public image
also influenced later generations
this is plagiarism notice that the
student substituted a few words
thrifty for economical audacious
lifestyle for life of adventure
and rearranged a few things and changed
a few other things like had a strong
influence to strongly influenced
these changes are just cosmetic these
are not the students own words
these are not his or her thought these
are the words and thoughts of the
original author
one could have rewritten the text
without having any understanding of
hemingway or of what a thrifty or
understated style even means
or what his lifestyle was
when you're writing about others ideas
or writing from sources
you need to understand and digest the
material well enough
so that you can put it in your own words
this means you're probably going to need
to go to multiple sources to adequately
understand the subject matter
as you're collecting source material
it's okay to cut and paste passages from
other people's work to get everything in
one place
like in one word document but put those
passages in quotation marks
so you don't later forget that those
aren't your words
and when you go to write about it work
from memory never start with someone
else's text
and just move their words around by the
time you're ready to write
you should understand the material well
enough to be able to start from scratch
draw your own conclusions come up with
your own ideas on the topic
that's what you need to do to avoid
plagiarism
another thing that students are often
less aware of is the concept of
self-plagiarism
self-plagiarism is recycling your own
writing or your own data from one
published paper to the next
it's also unethical in addition you may
be violating copyright laws from the
journal that owns the published paper
you are not supposed to plagiarize even
from your own work
one possible exception to this is that
there may be some duplication of text
within the materials and methods section
for example there may be only so many
ways to explain what you did to the
cells
so if you've used the same experiment
across multiple studies
there may be some text repeated it
shouldn't be a complete copy
but if you explain some of the materials
and methods in the same way
in multiple papers journal editors are
usually fine with that
but everything else should be new
authors also sometimes engage in
something that's akin to plagiarism
which is duplication of their old
results
and their old data sometimes an author
will take a data set that's already
published
and maybe add a little bit of new data
or tweak the data slightly
and present the whole thing as a new
paper this is misleading because it's
putting things out there
as if they were two independent pieces
of information supporting a hypothesis
when there isn't
it's padding the medical literature with
superfluous papers
and there's also of course a copyright
issue
interestingly there are research being
conducted to go through the literature
and figure out exactly how prevalent is
plagiarism in the scientific literature
there was a story in nature where they
reported that in pilot tests of the
plagiarism detection software crosscheck
some journals found that six percent to
23 percent of submitted manuscripts had
to be rejected due to plagiarism
that is a very high percentage
another study used automatic detection
software
and then they manually confirmed
plagiarism in submitted papers
they found that eight percent of the
papers had plagiarized other people's
work
and about three percent involved
self-plagiarism
so again we're ranging around 10 of the
papers having significant plagiarism
another group of researchers did a study
of plagiarism in the personal statements
for residency applications
these were doctors who were applying to
do their residency
the researchers used a plagiarism
detection software to review about five
thousand personal statements
and then they confirmed suspected
plagiarism manually
they found that five percent of essays
had clear evidence of plagiarism
meaning one in 20 of the doctors
applying for residency had plagiarized
so plagiarism is a significant problem
be careful in your own work to put
everything in your own words
in summary in order to write something
original
you have to go to enough sources so that
you can figure out for yourself
about the topic you are writing you have
to understand enough to be able to
generate new ideas
and that's what you need to do to avoid
plagiarism